officer is facing quote level one
critical incident investigation I don't
know what the hell that means it's
talking level one night that's
that's good Banger ahead yeah but maybe
She Bangs her head all the time maybe
she banged her and she was like that all
you got
[Music]
recently a 95 year old woman with
dementia was tasered by police officers
at a nursing home Colleen's a fan of
this good
good because she won't remember family
that's wild also tasers are wild I just
got one one like a police grade taser
you did yeah yeah oh to protect yourself
yeah I got a lot of weapons in my house
is it like shooting tasers or is it like
the one that you just like put on
somebody it's just where you put it to
somebody but it's like I forget the
voltage but it's wild even says police
on it is it really loud did you like it
it's so loud yeah I kind of want to oh
I'm scared that's not Nick he loves it
yeah should I bring it who wants to test
it I'm scared be a woman don't be scared
women are scared I think you should test
it on an animal maybe
just kill it like a squirrel or maybe
test it on a pizza see if it melts the
cheese oh that's a good buy a frozen
pizza yeah yeah and if it melts the
cheese you're like okay this can melt
something no you can see like the the
[__] bloopy yeah yeah yeah how much
was it [__] uh literally 20 bucks what
yeah
it does I took it I tested it I was like
it scared me at first because it was so
loud bro the snap of it so loud I was
like oh holy [__] honest question do you
think you'll be able to use it yep
I think because when it's more of a
deterrent than anything yeah like just
you you want to do it before they get to
you right it's more of a deterrence so
that way people go oh well maybe I'll
second guess like I'll think I'll think
about this
um do I think it'll be useful in like
close combat situations and high stress
moments um probably not I don't know
depends on the situation really it's
good for road rage road rage moments
it's a good assistant I mean I think I'd
rather use the pepper spray first than
that just because I have distance
um I had the pepper sprays really good
because a friend of mine's a former cop
she said it's awesome because um you
know because they they get tested they
have to do it all she said it's great
because it causes pain
hours later yeah and when they take a
shower it starts up again yeah yeah so I
think that would be more effective than
trying to be like okay I'm gonna get
into like a close combat situation and
try and use this taser because the other
thing
is I they'll probably be able to take
the taser away from me and use it on me
so if I at least have some sort of
distance involved use a pepper spray
distances but Colleen got some big
uppercuts though she got good also being
buff because if you hear someone in the
other room and you just with your with
your off hand you click the taser and
they could hear it but they're like oh I
don't care and then you'll have the
pepper spray in your dominoes oh yeah I
got I got options I got I got options
dual wielding that noise was scared no
the noise is really yeah like so on your
iPhone like that or whatever it sounds
like what about just [__] hairspray
in a lighter whoa yo let's go the good
old Aqua Net cocktail the guy comes out
with no eyebrows but it's faced this way
when you accidentally separate yeah yeah
but then but then you're gonna go to
jail yeah that's true whatever happened
to a good old-fashioned string and a
paint can dude what about that or a
bucket of water on top of the [__]
door
laughs
or like a busted pearl necklace on the
ground
so are you gonna say that her memory
came back after being tased uh that
would have been amazing it wasn't gonna
get worse actually uh so detectives were
investigating the use of a taser on the
elderly woman in Australia uh they were
responding to a call that the 95 year
old had taken a steak knife from the
care home kitchen and was subsequently
tasered by police after the fact when
she was struck uh or tasered she fell
and struck her head on the floor oh my
God suffering from critical injuries
before being taken to the district
Hospital okay like I hate saying this
but you know when people always go like
couldn't they have just got the knife
out of her using some other subdue
method she's 95 yeah
couldn't they have done some other
subduement
you know that it's a steak Knife I can't
even cut a well done T-Bone with that
what if she's been doing CrossFit for
like 20 years yeah well she's really fit
she's the exception what's that you know
this in the Spider-Man origin movies
when like he realizes he's fast and the
guy's punching him and it's he sees it
in slow motion I feel like this is the
situation
it's like in slow motion it's also a
steak Knife that's not even the like of
all the knives and also like the most
General steak knives are usually extra
dual yeah and if it's in a what is it in
her house or a retirement a care home
steak oh yeah it's a butter knife no
one's eating the steak in there would
you rather have
stick the dog on her no what about
pepper spray pepper spray be a better
solution
yeah a battery Ram
she's a crazy lady she might be like
stop everybody I'll stab myself and you
don't want to stab yourself either so
you're like oh [__] you could probably
just mind game her by literally putting
a stake in front of her and going oh
good Blanche you got you got everything
you need
her give her a fork yeah hey hurry up go
make a perfectly medium worse or you
could just like trade for something or
like you know have that knife and go
like hey this knife's better yeah give
me that knife first and I'll give you
this one and it's a butter knife oh like
yeah dude you could probably play all
kinds she's 95. see these are the
tactics oh you're talking about like the
Frank Sinatra impersonator oh yeah I
think it's a nice Filipino
dang dude tasinger I don't know the the
police have addressed the incident
um saying that body cam recordings from
the officer showed confronting footage
which would form part of their internal
investigation they said it would not be
in the public interest to be releasing
that footage and the officer who fired
the taser was off duty you know what
that means right they're not they're not
releasing someone already bought the
rights AFV probably yeah America's
Funniest Videos
or it's possible as possible have you
ever tased an elderly no I wonder what
happens I don't know
[Music]
off and he was off he was off yeah hey
you do it no um you do it you're off
duty oh that's a good idea why why is he
even there why does he have a body
camera yeah what I don't get is why does
it matter if he's off duty like like
because they put that thinking that it's
gonna matter to people like oh he's off
duty this guy's a civilian tailoring old
lady so just to show that nobody called
911 to bring a dispatching officer or
maybe they say he's off duty so that the
uh the actual Precinct can't get in
trouble for it ah does that [__] work
it's in Australia so the rules might be
different
oh and it's in Australia yeah oh man
they have all funny accents is there
Silver Linings to this story there's a
silver knife
wow I thought it was like
so she didn't get her memory back or
anything I think the Silver Linings is
that it's in Australia imagine
that's nice oh I love Sydney Bart
creates his own narrative and then
questions why there's no solution to his
narrative yeah I thought it was gonna be
like you know like it comes like full
circle so all this talk up and no memory
has been regained yeah what the [__] is
the point of this article that's good
news that is good news but if someone
doesn't remember no PTSD did she still
press charges or she doesn't have to
anymore I think the family will yeah
well it's not well if Austria is the
same as America it's not up to them it's
up to the the D.A oh all right hey but
if it was your family member who's like
your grandma or something and she got
tased because she had a steak knife out
like how would you feel my grandma was
feisty that's all I was kind of like
because my Grandma had Alzheimer's too
yeah and then
um because in their mind like when they
have Alzheimer's whatever they're
fighting for becomes life or death yeah
because she doesn't believe that in
everyone's reality is different from
unreal yeah so for example uh my grandma
she has to take all these like medicines
like blood pressure whatever and then in
the beginning she'd be like Oh I'm gonna
take it and then my grandpa's like no no
you took it already you don't need to
take it she goes no I need to take it I
didn't take it yet yeah and then so it
became okay now let's sign the the pill
thing and she's like who forged my
signature yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
like why is someone forging my signature
I need to take you trying to kill me are
you trying to [__] kill me and then
so it gets like it starts escalating
yeah so now like let's say if uh okay we
need to go for our walk grandma
and then we have people like hired to
like help her and she'll like fight them
like I don't [__] need to go for a
walk so it becomes really really crazy
my grandma never like busted a knife out
or whatever but I can imagine the 95
year old lady like for the smallest
things like fighting for life or death
because yeah her reality is different
from you it's totally different yeah so
you're saying it was okay that they
tased her I'm saying that I
can empathize a little bit
true though right so you're saying it's
okay that Russia invaded Ukraine yes
okay
because I've seen my grandma like flip
her [__] over stuff and I'm like and
that's family and if she was in a senior
citizen's home and you got one grandma
going ape [__] over here another grandma
going ape [__] like everyone's going ape
[__] it's just East just go
I'm just like I'm impressed that she she
didn't die because she's within the
bracket of people that you you're not
supposed to taste as a train officer
right because then they just die or
falling right like yeah there's like
these people can't fall so maybe she is
kind of able to to kill you
facing quote level one critical incident
investigation I don't know what the hell
that means this is Australian talk yeah
yeah
nothing which is a category for injuries
which lead to death or imminent death
because she did bang her head yeah but
maybe She Bangs her head all the time
maybe she banged her and she was like
that all you got like that's [__]
scary dude imagine I need more tasers
yeah there's just shocking the [__] out
of her oh my God
[Music]
laughs